[Music]
on this Sunday night a high-stakes NATO
Summit the security Alliance faces tough
decisions on Ukraine Russia's aggression
will not pay why the meeting is sparking
security concerns and the Canadian
military Mission set to be extended
the heat is on more weather warnings for
millions of Canadians and Americans
another blow to Afghan women in the
workforce what we are going to do after
this what the Taliban is targeting now
plus a shortage of spice some get mad at
me restaurants are taking heat after a
pause and production of hot sauce
global national with foreign reporting
tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with what could be a
critical week for the future of Ukraine
with no end in sight to Russia's
Invasion NATO leaders are gathering in
Lithuania for a key Summit the world's
biggest security Alliance is divided on
several issues including if and how
Ukraine should be granted membership the
Ukrainian president plans to attend the
annual meeting this week looking for
security guarantees
we would like to have all the decisions
to be made during The Summit in this
case it's obvious that I'll be there and
I'll be doing whatever I can in order to
so to speak expedite that solution to
have an agreement with our partners
prime minister Justin Trudeau will also
attend the NATO Summit and on his way to
Lithuania he'll stop first in Latvia
where Canada has its largest overseas
military deployment our chief political
correspondent David Aiken will be
traveling with the Prime Minister David
well Jeff the stop in regalatvia is an
important prelude for prime minister
Justin Trudeau ahead of the NATO Summit
in the Lithuanian capital of Vilnius in
Riga Monday morning the Prime Minister
will meet with the 800 or so Canadian
troops who were part of a NATO battle
group station there he was last there in
the spring of 2022. Trudeau will also
meet with his Latvian counterpart and
they are expected to announce that
Canada will commit to an extended
military presence in Latvia remember
earlier this year Canada announced it
would send a squadron of 15 tanks to
join this battle group those tanks are
expected to depart via ship from
Montreal in the fall then on Tuesday and
Wednesday Trudeau joins other NATO
leaders in Vilnius for what some
analysts say may be the most important
NATO Summit in decades on the agenda
NATO expansion boosting defense spending
and Military deployments in Europe and
of course the war in Ukraine for 500
Days Moscow has brought death and
destruction to the heart of Europe
seeking to destroy Ukraine and divide
NATO
our Summit will send a clear message
NATO stands United and Russia's
aggression will not pay this will also
be one of the most heavily defended NATO
Summits ever Vilnius is just 30
kilometers from the border with Russia's
Ally Belarus and Russia itself is less
than 300 kilometers away this situation
is really very tense because of
aggression of Russian Federation against
Ukraine so it's already on a very very
uh high level the prime minister is
expected to return to Canada on Thursday
Jeff David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
the U.S president will also attend this
week's NATO Summit of course he's
departing today and stopping first for a
brief visit to Britain Joe Biden will
meet with King Charles and British prime
minister Rishi sunak before leaving for
Lithuania on Tuesday
back here in Canada there's a glimmer of
hope in the BC Port strike which is now
into its ninth day talks between the
port workers union and their employers
resumed this weekend after breaking down
last week Grace Key joins us from
Vancouver where workers have gathered
for a rally Grace
a massive turnout at Jack pool Plaza in
downtown Vancouver There Were Striking
union members and local and
international labor leaders they came
from the United States New Zealand and
Australia they said they had two
messages one was a shared struggle for
workers to get Fair compensation during
these tough Economic Times and the
second to show solidarity they pointed
out shipping companies and terminals
have made record profits especially
during the pandemic when members
continued working to keep the economy
moving work is not only on Landstar but
workers around this country workers
non-union workers unions should never
apologize for the money the benefits
that they earn because the profits at
these corporate [__] take from us is
our money
the BC Maritime employers Association
did release a statement on Saturday they
said that both sides met on Saturday
with a federal mediator and that
proposals were made and rejected so now
they do await the direction from those
Federal mediators Jeff Grace Key in
Vancouver thanks Grace
protesters rallied outside a Montreal
graveyard today frustrated over a strike
that's kept Canada's largest cemetery
closed to the public since January
mourners are demanding the Quebec
government intervene after a tentative
agreement between the union and
management fell apart last month
hundreds of bodies have gone unburied
and the grounds have fallen into
disrepair with weeds growing waist high
and debris from an ice storm in April
still hasn't been cleaned up
the city of Winnipeg is giving
protesters at a local landfill site
until tomorrow afternoon to remove their
blockade the protest there began
Thursday after Manitoba's Premier
confirmed the province will not conduct
a surge of another landfill for the
bodies of two missing women Winnipeg
Police believe the remains of Morgan
Harris and Mercedes Myron are in the
prairie green landfill an alleged serial
killer is charged with their murders the
premier says it's up to the federal
government to decide whether to search
speaking with global news today
protesters denied reports that they
planned to leave insisting the blockade
will remain
the heat wave gripping most of Canada is
showing no signs of cooling temperatures
are soaring from coast to coast to coast
heat warnings are in place for six
provinces and two territories with
temperatures exceeding 30 degrees across
several regions and conditions are even
more extreme South of the Border the U.S
national weather service has issued
dangerous heat alerts for tens of
millions of Americans Global National's
new Houston correspondent Jamie Maraca
reports
measuring summer months
and productivity for this Ohio farmer we
start early in the morning and try to
you know try to beat the Heat
that's so extreme in some areas it's
forcing over 50 million Americans to do
whatever they can to stay cool
in the hardest hit Southwest Phoenix
Arizona typically stifling this time of
year hasn't had a day under 40 degrees
celsius all month long
and there are warnings of the Mercury
climbing to near 50 in the coming days
reaching that number would break an
all-time record if you listen to the
scientists which not enough people are
the last week they have described as
terrifying
and as Uncharted Territory Daniel
Johnson has studied heat waves for two
decades and points the finger at a
pronounced El Nino season and a change
in climate as greenhouse gases trap heat
in the atmosphere extreme heat events
are one of the principal effects
expected with that comes the increase
risk of wildfires
has already burned this year and smoke
has polluted air quality across the
country reaching South of the Border we
need to bring the emissions of these
heat trapping gases down to zero and
then we need to be removing greenhouse
gases from the atmosphere the continuing
heat Dome recently put parts of Texas
amongst the hottest places on Earth now
experts say we need to focus on cooling
the climate down in order to prevent our
summers from heating up Jeff Jamie
moroccer keeping cool in Houston thanks
Jamie
the relationship status between the U.S
and China has been complicated for a
while with tensions over Taiwan Chinese
surveillance balloons and allegations of
genocide over beijing's treatment of
uyghur Muslims but the two superpowers
say it's time to patch things up and to
that end the U.S treasury secretary
traveled to Beijing for some high-stakes
diplomacy Mackenzie gray has the details
it's not the Pomp and Circumstance you'd
usually see for a major international
trip but U.S treasury secretary Janet
yellen's visit to China is an
opportunity to reset one of the most
important International relationships
the U.S and China have significant
disagreements
those disagreements need to be
communicated clearly and directly and
Yellen did just that in meetings with
some of China's top officials but there
seemed to be no progress made on issues
like the war in Ukraine and what Yellen
calls unfair economic practices by
Beijing these conversations were Direct
we were able to learn more about each
other's economies and policy choices
which I believe is vital as the world's
two largest economies and those
economies have been soaring together
from iPhones to solar panels to soybeans
the two biggest economies in the world
have exchanged 700 billion dollars worth
of goods in the last year a new record
the trade alone can't bridge the gap on
major issues like beijing's treatment of
the Muslim uyghur minority problems in
Hong Kong and a potential invasion of
Taiwan which could bring the two
countries into direct conflict right now
I'm particularly worried because
it seems like the two countries the
United States and China
have given up on one another U.S
President Joe Biden has spent hundreds
of billions to try and lure jobs back to
the States from China in key businesses
like microchip production that's a
sector the administration will soon put
new rules on limiting American
Investment in Chinese microchip firms
there is a lot of friction about trade
related as well as geopolitical
in terms of how both countries are
drifting apart and where there are today
and where they're likely to be in the
near future those new American rules on
microchip Investments are still being
written but Joe Biden has another major
decision to make whether or not he'll
keep in place billions of dollars worth
of tariffs on China that is potential
2024 opponent Donald Trump slapped on
Beijing
Jeff Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks
Mack
unrest in Israel
coming up protests reignite ahead of a
crucial vote on that controversial
judicial Reform Bill plus
this is the very poignant evening
Elton John's emotional farewell
[Music]
Israel's prime minister appears to be
losing patience with protesters rallying
against his hugely controversial
judicial reforms critics argue the
changes will undermine democracy and
weaken the power of the courts a key
vote on The Proposal is set for tomorrow
and comes one week after Israeli forces
launched a deadly raid on a Palestinian
refugee camp in the occupied West Bank
Redmond Shannon explains how the
prospect of peace and the future of
Israel's justice system are connected
a delegation of European diplomats
navigates what's left of parts of Janine
in the occupied West Bank the Israeli
Defense Forces raid there earlier in the
week killed 12 and left roads and homes
in rubble Mahmoud surveys what's left of
his house too
he says the outside world has ignored
the plight of Palestinians for 75 years
and he thinks nothing much is going to
change Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says the goal of the raid was
to Stamp Out militant bases but low-tech
explosive Labs can be quickly rebuilt
and deadly raids only Stoke more anger
according to analyst Professor yossi
mecklberg if you look further than the
immediate it's solves absolutely nothing
again it makes actually a situation
worse we see the timing again
especially with Gaza for instance
a 90-minute drive from Janine noise and
anger in Tel Aviv we don't know no one
knows what will
six months of disruptive protests have
pushed against netanyahu's proposed
changes to Israel's justice system as
the longtime leader fights his own legal
battles against allegations of
corruption and fraud the so-called
reasonableness Bill gets its first
reading in Parliament Monday which
critics argue will reduce the power of
the courts to overrule government
decisions
on Sunday Netanyahu called for a review
into whether police should intervene
more strongly in protests the Janine
raids may have been a convenient
distraction from his plans for the
courts but the issues do overlap too the
Supreme Court protects and defense and
secure and guarantees
human rights and political rights on one
side actually approves expansion of
settlements on occupied lands selling of
houses demolishing of houses the week
ended in Israel land of the West Bank
with more funerals not deaths from the
Janine raids but from a Revenge attack
that followed the seemingly never-ending
spiral of violence and grief shows
little sign of slowing down Redmond
Shannon Global News London
[Music]
repressive regime still ahead why the
Taliban is targeting Afghanistan's
beauty salons
[Music]
welcome back it's been almost two years
since the Taliban retook control of
Afghanistan Reviving their Relentless
oppression on the rights and freedoms of
women and girls the U.N calls it gender
apartheid and says Afghanistan is the
most repressive country in the world for
women and it seems the Taliban isn't
done yet Global shagufa Adonis reports
on the regime's latest Crackdown
beauty salons are one of the last safe
heaven for women in Afghanistan they too
are about to disappear the Taliban has
ordered salons clothes and one month
what we are going to do after this 28
year old Fatima opened her business five
years ago and has five employees
you are worried about how to survive
right now we lost everything even our
hope our wishes our future Jamila is
also devastated that she and her 30
colleagues will soon be out of work
we can't feed ourselves without this
beauty salon
the Taliban is Banning salons claiming
their work is forbidden by Islam and
that their service are too expensive for
Grooms who pay during weddings it's all
part of a larger effort to arrest women
from public life
the Taliban has barred women and girls
from schools universities and most jobs
it seems that Taliban starts their day
in the morning thinking of what else has
left for women so that we can ban and
with restrict Afghanistan's twelve
thousand salon owners are now preparing
to close but the decision will affect
thousands more many of these women are
the main Breadwinners of their families
this will only create more hardship 95
percent of people in Afghanistan live
below their poverty line there should be
something done to to stop this atrocity
and this
crisis that's going on against women in
the country either organization an
Afghan woman fear There Will Be Few
consequences
they want women in Afghanistan to
disappear
an edit robbing woman of their income
and your dignity
Global News
Ottawa
hot sauce shortage up next why spice
lovers have been left out in the cold
[Music]
the Rocket Man is retiring saying
goodbye to the yellow brick road after
almost 4 600 performances over an
incredible 52 years Elton John has
performed his final concert though he
says there may be one-offs in the future
the 76 year old's Marathon farewell tour
kicked off in 2018 and was supposed to
end in 2021 but both the pandemic and a
hip injury delayed that while John says
he's done touring he plans to continue
working on new music
and a concert of a much different sort
is Making Waves in the Florida Keys
these Under the Sea musicians aren't
actually playing instruments instead
they're miming along to music piped
through waterproof speakers under the
boats above the underwater Music
Festival is held every year to advocate
for coral reef preservation the Florida
Keys is home to the only living barrier
Coral Reef in the continental U.S
as temperatures soar a lot of people are
trying to beat the heat others though
still want to spice things up by dousing
their food with hot sauce that is if you
can find a bottle Mike Jolie explains
what's fueling the hot sauce shortage
that has some spice lovers getting salty
hot sauce lovers are always asking for
more heat the Farms that produce them
right now heat is their biggest problem
Mexico like large swaths of Canada is
caught in an epic Heat Wave 45 degree
temperatures combined with depleted
Water Supplies have Farmers like Antonio
hoping for a miracle
there's been no rainfall so we have to
irrigate the crops manually he says but
the drought is so severe there's no
water for irrigation it sure looks good
spice of life a manufacturer north of
Toronto relies on those Mexican Peppers
to give its product that extra punch
she's hot she is hot Ontario Peppers
aren't ripe until late summer or early
fall leaving owner Nadia Harlow in a
pinch I have face challenges trying to
get peppers I've had to discontinue one
of my popular sauces just based on the
fact that I just cannot find the peppers
for that the shortage is becoming an
annual occurrence the incredibly popular
Hui Fong Sriracha which uses the red
jalapeno hybrid Chili Pepper from Mexico
has had supply issues since 2020 forcing
restaurants to adapt some get mad
fan well the thing that we lied to them
but we offered them other kind of
thoughts and they they just don't want
to try on Amazon a hard to find pack of
two Sriracha sauces is selling for a
hundred and ten dollars there's more on
eBay selling for equally Preposterous
prices but at least sanity prevailed
with zero bids for this open and expired
bottle if the drought continues in
Mexico Canadian producers may have to
look at Alternatives such as growing
more of their own because there's no
shortage of demand for that sweet sweet
heat I think it's still building hot
microwave Global News
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is a Callaway where
residents are celebrating Nunavut day on
this day 30 years ago parliament passed
the Nunavut land claims agreement act
which gave the Inuit people a separate
portion of the Northwest Territories to
call their own none of it didn't become
legally independent until April 1st of
1999 but the signing of the Act was
hugely significant and so the annual
holiday is now observed on July the 9th
happy birthday Nunavut and thanks for
watching Donna will be back here with
you tomorrow have a great night
thank you